hi my name is uterus and you're about to
watch my brand-new trailer for my film
yadi I really hope you enjoy it and see
in cinemas soon
Dez young Jamaican and him he loses his
brother his only family we take him the
story through these eyes and his journey
Kingston Jamaica King Fox control the
streets deliver the goods to recall our
semolina London everyone beams to be
immersed in it the smoke and the sound
I'm on first there trust me one lower
thief we wanted to make a
three-dimensional character that was
weighty and complex will you go in the
right chest
when you go down yonder stay out of
trouble now hope people enjoy the beauty
of this film is exciting and Gribble I
sent you to London so you wouldn't start
a war in Kingston
when I was a boy my brother would always
ask me which way you're gonna go
we're gonna ride chess I will you go
with it down this is a story about the
part I chose Kingston Jamaica King Fox
control the streets in tell me to forget
about my brother Willie omission deliver
the goods to Rico when it is done you
let me know
yes I'm Alan London I had to do is
deliver Dakota Rico I'm I never liked it
first time so I'm on first time trust me
I love it
[Applause]
for years I haven't seen anybody be for
daddy Dave for Dennis welcome here for
change my life
forget away from Kingston look at
yourself degree never left you just
killed my dog
no you're better getting shot down like
that ancient history they are trouble
masks ever deliver the goods to Rico but
frosty Rio Rico
is a liability me alpha do you
understand
can't obvious nonsense our only
I just gone back to Jamaica sometimes I
might have to choose his own path I sent
you to London so you wouldn't start a
war increased
[Music]
you